bonjour sévit poncet merci d'être en
direct avec nous ce matin alors les
mesures adoptées sont elles suffisantes
et répond-t-elle à vos revendications
non enfin elles ne répondent pas aux
revendications de la cgt est sûrement
pas aux attentes et des agents et des
salariés puisque un effet toutes ces
mesures en fait ne correspondent pas du
tout à notre revendication principale
c'est à dire nous nous avions demandé
l'année dernière par le biais du ségur
une augmentation du point d'indicé est
gelé depuis plus de dix ans je vous
rappelle dans la fonction publique et
qui pour l'instant n'a pas de réponse et
toutes les annonces qui ont été faites
lundi en fait ne sont pas l'adéquation
avec nos attentes
voilà parce que nos grilles nous ne les
avons pas ces fameuses grille la cgt
n'ayant pas signé les accords du ségur
nous n'avons pas ces grilles un mois
quand je vois les salaires qui sont
proposés enfin qui sont donc à proposer
qui sont donnés jeu c'est vrai que ça
fait rêver mais nous sommes loin de la
réalité du terrain et beaucoup de
professionnels sont exclues de ces
grilles
donc non ça ne correspond pas du tout à
nos attentes nous aurions aimé à une
augmentation du point d indice nous
aurions aimé l'arrêt des fermetures de
vie qui continue d'un tous les intrus
des hôpitaux
nous aurions aimé un blanc dans gauche
massif et ce n'est pas le camp voilà
justement aujourd'hui plus d'un an après
la crise quelle est la réalité du
terrain
bel arrêt du terrain ce qui a toujours
des fermetures de lits que ne sont
toujours pas attractif que nos salaires
effectivement certains certains ont pris
183 euros
donc le public et grâce à la bataille
que nous avons mené ces derniers mois
les le secteur médico-social rattachés
aux établissements publics mais nous
sommes encore un bataille pour les
cantonales c'est à dire selon les
établissements qui sont la fonction
publique hospitalière mais autonomes qui
ne sont pas attachés l'établissement un
hôpital nous sommes encore en bataille
pour le secteur médico-social du privé
non lucratif
voilà et nous ne pouvons pas
ces petits que certains et 183 euros et
pas les autres
et dans ce qui a été dit lundi par
monsieur vers ans qui n'étaient pas en
fait une surprise puisque ça nous
l'avions vu déjà l'année dernière dans
le ségur certains corps de métiers sont
exclus les ash les techniques que les
administratifs donc non ça correspond
pas à nos attentes en voilà il suffisait
d'augmenter le point d'indicé de le
déjeuner de l'augmenter hélas aurait pu
correspondre à nos attentes
voilà alors on sent bien beaucoup de
déception dans dans votre discours vous
déclarez que la bataille n'est pas
terminée
quelles sont les actions que vous
comptez justement mener dans les
prochains jours ben justement je suis
aujourd'hui en réunion avec toute la
direction de la nationale
si j'étais à santé action sociale nous
sommes en train de prévoir une certaine
à une certaine ligne de conduite pour
justement que non non ne pas laisser nos
salariés sur la touche parce que ce qui
a été dit le dinh n'est pour moi que du
buzz médiatique
si vous voulez dans le sens sur
effectivement tout ce qui a été annoncé
les augmentations salariales font rêver
mais moi personnellement je suis
infirmière et je suis loin
je suis très près de lui ma fin de
carrière est juste très loin des 3300
euros annoncés par monsieur vers ans
donc je pense que beaucoup de mes
collègues sont dans ce cas là donc nous
nous allons contre nous allons continuer
à communiquer et à faire en sorte de
pouvoir espérer gagner
ce dégel du point d indice qui était un
fait notre priorité
dernière question mais ce ségur de la
santé vous a tout de même apporté
quelque chose de positif
alors oui bien sûr je ne vais pas vous
dire que ça n'a pas apporté ça a permis
les 183 euros pour certains ça nous a
permis aussi de d'être pris en
considération quand même parce
qu'effectivement ça faisait longtemps
que les salariés de la santé étaient en
souffrance mais quand j'ai la santé et
médico sociale qui étaient en souffrance
et donc et qui n'est pas pour l'instant
reconnu parce que
la santé ce n'est pas que l'hôpital ce
n'est pas que le secteur sanitaire il ya
tout le médico social derrière et il ya
toutes les toutes ces structures qui
accueillent des enfants handicapés non
nos personnes âgées il ya tout ça et oui
c'est grâce à notre bataille de ces
dernières années de ce je dirais de ces
trois dernières années nous avons fait
jouer d'action tout le temps toute
l'année qui a permis effectivement
d'ouvrir ce secure bien sûr que je peux
pas dire que le seigneur nous a apporté
mais il ne répond pas toutes nos
attentes et je vous dis la principale
attente c'était le dégel du point d
indice la reconnaissance de la
pénibilité pour nos catégories les
infirmières aides-soignantes les nous
sommes passé certaines en catégorie
sédentaire ce qui veut dire que nous
perdons la pénibilité
ça ne répond pas à tous mais ça nous a
permis quand même d'être visible mais je
pense que c'est aussi la crise qu vide
qui nous a permis d'être visible sauf
que actuellement nous avions les les
applaudissements l'année dernière cette
année nous avons moins la culpabilité de
ne pas me faire vacciner
nous avons encore beaucoup de choses à
montrer et je vois que mes collègues
sont toujours sur le terrain en
souffrance moi même je suis reparti
travailler il ya peu de temps sur mon
service
et voilà nous sommes toujours en
souffrance parce que nous manquons
d'effectifs
voilà donc en fait c'est un cercle
vicieux en manque d'effectifs ont fermé
lit on ne les trouvera pas on ouvre des
lieux éphémères
enfin tout ça fait que noms ne sont pas
encore dans l'euphorie de ce qui a été
annoncé lundi
voilà il ya beaucoup de choses encore
qu'il va falloir qu'on nous prouve un et
voilà notamment de faire le tri où ces
avancées salariales sont faramineuses
parce que nous ne les avons pas n'étions
pas signataire et voilà merci beaucoup
en tout cas ses réponses d'avoir répondu
à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
fédéral santé action sociale de la
sécurité